serious here all right our our next talk
is from sam hopkins at berkeley are
their information computation gaps
unique to
and in high probability heavy-tailed
estimation
yeah thanks chris uh and all the
organizers um
this talk is basically going to be a 25
minute infomercial
for uh an open problem or open direction
that that i think is
interesting and understudied that is uh
it's going to be about some recent work
which i think
hints at the potential existence of a
kind of information computation
gap that we haven't really seen before
to my
knowledge so this is based on joint work
with yeshwanth tarun
prasad and nalesh here at berkeley
so the game that we're going to be
interested in
is um high probability estimation
in the high dimensions so for
statisticians this is
an estimation where we pay attention to
confidence intervals
so the game generically abstractly will
be this given
some number n of independent samples
from some high dimensional probability
distribution
p theta parametrized by some parameters
theta
estimate these parameters theta by some
theta hat which is close to theta
in some norm where close is measured by
some
number that i will call the rate the
error rate and we'll think of these of a
rate as depending on
the number of samples the ambient
dimension of
of these samples and the probability
with which we are willing to fail
so this this our rate is also the radius
of a one minus delta confidence
interval um of course in the real world
you might want this to depend on more
things
like some some geometry some underlying
geometry of the
problem you're considering but to keep
things simple we'll just think about
number of samples
dimension and confidence level
and we're going to be interested in what
happens when you try to do
basic estimation problems for very large
classes of distributions i will try to
make the weakest possible assumptions
on the distributions in question like
maybe i would like to allow p
theta to be any distribution with a
small number of bounded moments
and this is in contrast to the kind of
assumptions that one often makes when
analyzing confidence intervals one often
assumes gaussian-ness or subgaussiness
which is a much stronger kind of
assumption
but our goal will be to match the kind
of guarantees you would get if you were
working with gaussian distributions
but drop strong assumptions to be much
more permissive in what kind of
distributions we can handle
so let me illustrate with uh
maybe the two most basic problems in
high dimensional estimation
one is estimating the mean of a random
variable um
so that's in this case the norm we'll
consider will just be l2 the euclidean
norm and the parameters we want are just
the expectation of the random variable
and the second is covariance estimation
where my goal is to estimate
uh let's just assume the mean is zero so
that you're really just estimating the
second
moment you want to estimate the
covariance
and the norm i'm going to be interested
in is operator norm maximum eigenvalue
maximum magnitude eigenvalue
just as some bookkeeping so that i can
make it a bit easy to write things for
this talk all the distributions that i
will consider
um will have covariances that are
kind of very loosely approximately
identity in the following sense
their trace should be like um
some constant times the ambient
dimension and their maximum eigenvalue
should be
some constant independent of dimension
this is not needed for any of the
theorems that i'll say in the talk but
it makes
it easier to kind of um compare compare
things quantitatively
okay so these are my two problems two
most basic problems in
in uh in high dimensional estimation um
let's
talk about the state of the art oh what
i meant to
clear this slide so
i gave away my own punch line here but
that's fine so i'm going to define
some magic number called r star and r
star is going to be the confidence
interval
rate which shows up for a whole bunch of
different settings it's
some very fundamental quantity it's the
square root of ambient dimension divided
by square root of a number of samples
plus square root log 1 over delta over
number of samples
so um sorry i meant to fill this slide
in live but i'll just highlight live
so the first question is what if i let's
think about my benchmark case which is
gaussian distributions
what if i want to do the simplest thing
in the world which is estimate the mean
of a gaussian distribution in high
dimensions
with confidence intervals well if you
just do some
uh some standard concentration applied
to the empirical mean which is the best
estimator
you will find that this is the
confidence interval radius that you get
and you know this estimator can be
computed in polynomial time it's just
the empirical mean
so uh this is this is our benchmark for
estimation of the mean
now what if you want to drop a gaussian
assumption now the empirical mean is not
a good
choice the empirical meaning is not
robust to the kind of fluctuations that
you would see
if you wanted to make a much weaker
assumption just like
a constant number of bounded moments in
your distribution
it turns out though this is only
understood quite recently that at least
if you are willing to expend exponential
time and go beyond
the empirical mean as your estimator you
can compute some kind of a high
dimensional median some relative of the
two key median
and you can maintain up to constant
factors this
um this confidence interval radius r
star this is due to lugosi and
mendelssohn from
from 2018. and high dimensional medians
however are notoriously hard to compute
the tukey median is hard to compute in
the worst case this is some relative of
it so one might be worried that
this would be a strictly theoretical in
the sense that you wouldn't be able to
give a polynomial time analog but it
turned out that actually
in in the case of estimating the mean in
l2 it is
possible to do it in polynomial
time and still up to constant factors
preserve this optimal confidence
interval
rate r star so here in this talk by
polynomial time i usually mean
polynomial in n d and log one over delta
so this is a result from from 2018 and
that means of course you can do it in a
slightly slower running time and poly nd
one over delta which is more than
slightly slower it's exponentially
slower with respect to delta
yeah the high dimensional median is the
thing which uh minimizes the sum of the
l1 distances to all the data points is
that right yeah
uh not in this case that is a that's a
good question so i was
i'll show you actually the analog of the
median i'm interested in for covariance
estimation it's something more
complicated than that
the thing that you just there's no
there's no canonical high dimensional
median
actually the one you just described is
often called the geometric median
the two key median is slightly different
in this case what one wants is any point
which is close to a majority of the
samples in every univariate direction
in every univariate projection so this
is this is again different from
geometric median um yeah so
you know geometric median actually will
not get you this guarantee
in the case of covariance so what this
means is that in the case of estimating
the mean
everything has a nice kind of bow on it
you can do
information theoretically optimal
estimation in polynomial time
what about estimation of the covariance
the next most interesting
next most sophisticated high dimensional
estimation problem
well almost the whole story is the same
except the ending
so in the gaussian case if you just use
empirical covariance
in the parameter regime that i'm talking
about again you'll get this exact same
confidence interval radius this is kind
of an accident it's just because of the
way i set up the parameters but you'll
get
some optimal thing for gaussians this is
of course doable in polynomial time
because it's just the empirical
covariance
in exponential time if you just assume
something about fourth moments you can
match this using again some kind of
pretty sophisticated high dimensional
median
um it turns out that if you're willing
to run in time polynomial in
n and d but exponential and log one over
delta which is to say polynomial and one
over delta
then you can still match this this is a
result of ours from earlier this year
but i have no idea if you can match it
if you want truly polynomial running
time poly n
d log one over delta so um
this is the open problem i'm advertising
for this talk
uh and let me try to make the case that
it's not just some
some technical thing that there's
something qualitatively interesting
going on here
so the open problem is can you design a
polynomial time algorithm which takes
uh independent samples from some
distribution where you make only
assumptions on a few moments
of that distribution and out gives an
estimate theta hat of its covariance
such that theta minus theta hat in
operator norm
is small where small means this uh this
optimal quantity the thing you would
have gotten if you were working with
gaussians
i actually think there's a good chance
and we'll see see why
later in the in the talk i think there's
a good chance that this is
actually not possible and if it's not
possible that the other
half of the open problem is to give some
kind of rigorous evidence that no such
efficient algorithm
exists and this is where i think
something qualitatively different is
happening
this would be rigorous evidence for an
information computation gap
that has to somehow isolate the small
delta regime of estimation it's supposed
to apply only to very high probability
estimation notice that even if i make
only a small number of moment
assumptions
the empirical covariance still does a
good job it still does the right thing
for large deltas
um this is so this this really contrasts
with
something like planted clique or sparse
pca where
success probability of your estimator is
not really affecting whether your
problem is tractable or not it's really
about you know sparsity level or number
of samples
um it also has to apply only
to kind of highly non-gaussian
distributions again not something we're
used to
when we're giving evidence for
information computation gaps
because the empirical covariance would
work just fine for gaussian
distributions and and
and that's of course efficiently
computable so i have no idea how to give
rigorous evidence in this
in this situation but i think this means
that it if we could do it it would be a
qualitatively new kind of information
computation
so i have a question uh does the answer
to this question depend on the norm that
you're choosing to measure the distance
with respect to
like the operator norm versus the
hilbert schmidt norm etc
yeah i think i think in frobenius norm
um
okay i didn't check this
in detail ever but you know if you're
trying for benious norm or hilbert
schmidt norm
right that's just like the l2 norm of
some random vector
um and that we know how to do from
estimating the mean and l2 so this is
this is really about getting uh the
covariance right in a in a spectral
sense
you could talk about you know estimating
in luvnar order or you know in relative
in relative psd order that would
probably have this same
issue you know that's uh strictly harder
than what i'm asking you to do here
um and actually we that's yeah that's
that's a really hard problem i don't
know how to do that at all
um yeah thanks does that answer the
question okay
so in my remaining time i want to
sketch the current state-of-the-art
algorithms for
covariance estimation with um when
heavy-tailed distributions are
allowed heavy-tailed meaning i only
assume bounds on a constant number of
moments
and i want to suggest um this is this is
the hint of an information computation
gap it's at most a hint
but i want to show you why at least
current techniques seem to face
significant roadblocks to
to further improvement um but but but i
don't believe these are
yet fundamental roadblocks to any
polynomial time algorithm
okay so to do that
let's return to uh the exponential time
setting and just talk about these
results by lugosi and mendelssohn
and mendelssohn and javatovsky on some
kind of very fancy
high dimensional median based estimator
for the covariance
so as before the setup is going to be
that i get n samples they're d
dimensional vectors they're from some
probability distribution where i'm
assuming something only about a few
moments
and just for convenience let me assume
the expectation of that distribution is
zero
so the first step in in this estimator
actually in
basically all the estimators in this
area this is very standard
is you take your samples and you put
them into some buckets
at random don't look at the samples
before you do this
and you compute empirical averages
within each bucket so this is just some
kind of variance reduction
step in this case i take my samples i
put them into
log one over delta buckets turns out to
be the right number if i want
to to think about confidence level 1
minus delta
and within each bucket i compute the
empirical covariance so i'm going to
call those empirical covariances
z1 up to z log 1 over delta they are
of course d by d matrices
um and then we do something
fancy so now i have the z's
they are um independent unbiased
estimators of the covariance
but on their own they're no better than
the empirical covariance right they're
they're actually worse they don't give
you high
probability guarantees in the setting of
just a constant number of bounded
moments
so the the amazing trick by these folks
is to say that what you should do to
combine
these z one to z log one over delta is
compute what i'm going to call a
spectral r
center although that's not what they
called it but i like this terminology
better
which is a matrix m with the following
property and it's a bit complicated so
we'll try to
try to take it a little slow
it's a matrix m such that for every unit
vector v
for every l2 unit vector v if you look
at the quadratic form of your matrix m
at v and you look at the quadratic forms
of these zi matrices
at v the quadratic forms are close
for a majority of the zi's okay
so a spectral r center is one where they
where close means distance at most
r and uh the estimator is find in our
center for the minimal r such that that
exists it turns out that it will exist
for r equals r star
this optimal estimation rate
that's a non-trivial probability factor
to prove
so pictorially what's going on over here
is that uh you've got these matrices z1
z2 z3 and so on
and a spectral r center is any matrix m
such that when you
project all of these guys in the space
of d by d matrices
onto a rank 1 matrix that in this
projection
m is close to a majority of uh
of your guys in this case it's close to
two out of three of them that are within
distance
r so sam just to clarify
this is a little bit weaker than saying
that it's close in operator norm to
sixty percent of them
because which sixty percent precisely
precisely which vector i choose here
will
change which sixty percent i might be
close to
and that's creating all the algorithmic
difficulty actually just checking
closeness and operator norm to 60
of the guys not so hard but that turns
out
not to be an approach which will get you
the right guarantees
that will that will get you weaker
estimation guarantees if you make that
your definition of
center so this is a pretty sophisticated
definition it's not trivial to analyze
and it's it's pretty cool that these
folks manage to do it and prove
the following theorem uh
which says that if you use a spectral r
center
then up to logarithmic factors uh in d
you will get an opera you will get an
estimator which in operator norm is
optimally close with probability one
minus delta
assuming only a bound on the fourth
moments of your underlying random vector
so this is kind of amazing you don't
need gaussian at all you don't need
anything like it you just need fourth
moments
but of course i like algorithms and
the question is now can you compute an r
center a spectral r center
efficiently how on earth are you going
to do this notice that even if i
handed you a spectral r center it's not
really clear how you would even
check whether my point whether i give
you m and check whether it is or is not
a spectral r center because this
definition as chris points out
involves um some universal
quantification over
all rank one matrices over all unit
directions v
and um without doing some brute force
enumeration of those directions i don't
know
even how to check that uh that this m
has the spectral r center property
this is just to say it's not clear how
you would do this algorithmically
we are able to
give some partial progress in this
regard so here's here's the theorem
here in polynomial time
we are able to design an estimator
for high dimensional covariance of heavy
tail distributions
which has this funny-looking guarantee
this is this is the radius of its
confidence intervals and i've
highlighted this term log one over delta
to the one quarter
which is the amount by which we are off
from optimality
so this looks crazy i realize and it
looks like some some some bizarrely
technical thing but i'm going to give
you some evidence in just a moment
that that this is uh at least close to
optimal for the kind of techniques we're
using
so just to read it out our confidence
interval radius is
root d over n times log one over delta
to the one quarter
plus log one over delta over root uh
over n all to the uh to the one half and
just to offer you some comparison
let me rewrite the what you would have
gotten in the gaussian case
it's root d over n plus root log
1 over delta over n
we need to make an assumption a slightly
stronger assumption than
uh then lugosi and mendelsohn do we need
an assumption on eighth moments
and we need something called a
certifiability assumption
on those eighth moments this is
something pravesh also alluded to in his
talk
this is by now a sort of standard
assumption in
the robust and heavy-tailed statistics
literature
but the the the normal the normal
situation is that when you make an
assumption like this you get information
theoretically optimal estimators
and what's interesting here is that even
with this kind of assumption we still
don't achieve information theoretic
optimality notice however that
we are still sort of faithful to our
original goal which was make assumptions
only on a constant number of moments
um we have we have achieved that we
certainly don't need gaussianity or tail
you know strong tail bounds or anything
like that
so this is this is the main theorem let
me tell you briefly about the algorithm
and then what the roadblocks are to
information theoretic optimality via our
root
so our strategy is going to be to
to guess in some kind of lame way
some initial uh estimator
and then compute a series of iterates
until we arrive at our final estimator
m at each step of our iteration
we're going to attempt to certify that
um that my current guess my current
iterate
is a spectral r center and if i succeed
at that if i if i somehow determine that
it is a spectral r center
then i'll output it i'm done life is
good if i fail
then i'm going to hope that my
certification algorithm when it fails
i'm going to hope
that it produces some kind of witness to
that failure it tells me some direction
where i got the quadratic forms of lots
of my z's
wrong and then i will update my matrix
in some way to fix those quadratic forms
so the picture is this i remember that i
want to be a spectral center of these
matrices z1 up to z
log one over delta which were the
results of putting my samples in buckets
and computing empirical
covariances so if if my iterate uh the
iterator is sitting over here and
there's some direction
vv transpose where the z's actually all
live over here
then i'm hoping that when my
certification algorithm
fails it will tell me about this
direction and i will update
my um to this i plus first iterate along
this line
so that's the that's going to be the the
goal and the key
the key thing we need to make sure we
can do is this certification step
once we once we can design a
certification algorithm everything else
is
a reasonably standard analysis and
um the key sub problem in doing that
is to show that
if i gave you the truth if i gave you
the ground truth covariance
that you would be able to just to
certify that it
was indeed a spectral center of um
of these random matrices z1 to z log 1
over delta
so we are able to design a certification
algorithm which does exactly that
for some choice of r which is slightly
sub-optimal
in particular it's off by this log one
over delta to the one-quarter that i
mentioned before and that's of course
the origin of the sub-optimality in our
guarantees so we
we translate spectral r centronis into
some optimization problem
we relax that optimization problem to a
sum of squares semi-definite program
and we analyze the sum of squares
semi-definite program in the average
case when the z's are these random
matrices
to prove this guarantee this occupies
you know a great deal of technical work
that the awesome students at berkeley
handled with aplomb
um but let me point out once again that
this is not optimal
and in fact you can you can view the
difference between our algorithm and the
exponential time one through this lens
because
um the ground truth covariance
is actually a spectral r center for much
smaller r it's a spectral r center for
this
optimal choice of r and if you could
certify that i expect you would be able
to design an optimal algorithm
efficiently so in my final couple of
yeah
sam tim tim asks does the one quarter
improve if you make moment assumptions
beyond the eighth
great question you could do i don't know
how to i don't know how to do it
it might it the a sort of reasonable
kind of conjecture would be that if you
made
much higher yeah i really don't know
i thought that i sort of think the one
quarter might improve if you make higher
moment assumptions and you go
much higher in the sos hierarchy like
degree d to the epsilon or something
there might be an avenue to improving
things
um we can talk about it later but yeah i
don't know one quarter is
kind of a natural barrier you think for
like
constant degree let's say let me let me
give you the next slide and
then you can decide for yourself um
so the obvious question that tim is also
pointing out
is can you do certification
for smaller values of r right if you
could then as i said you probably would
improve
would improve our guarantees um
we offer some evidence that this seems
hard
to do to do the certification problem
and this is what i mean by evidence
that current approaches don't seem
improvable
past this log one over delta to the one
quarter the evidence is in the form of a
conjectured hard distribution for the
certification problem
the hard distribution is some joint
distribution
of samples x1 to xn they're not
independently distributed
anymore such that in my joint
distribution
the uh if i if i do my if i do my
bucketing
and i produce my matrices z the identity
matrix
fails to be an r center for this value
of r slightly below the value that we're
able to
to do certification for log one over
delta to the point two four
instead of 0.25
but no polynomial of small degree
which i think we're going to hear a lot
about this kind of evidence later but no
no polynomial jointly in the samples
of small degree is able to distinguish
this
uh joint distribution of samples from
just a
list of independent samples from normal
zero identity
from gaussian but in the gaussian case
the identity matrix
is an r center for much smaller values
of r
so we set up some some distinguishing
problem some hypothesis testing problem
that we think is hard we give some kind
of mild evidence
of hardness and
if this problem is hard then you
shouldn't be able to do certification
for r smaller than we are able to do
that would suggest
that the path to improving covariance
estimation in
this way is maybe closed
but of course this doesn't say very much
about the problem of heavy-tailed
covariance estimation
in general of course nobody says you
have to go at it via this
spectral r center approach or via
certifying algorithms
at all so i will close with the high
level question that i opened with
which is are there information
computation gaps that are unique
to the high probability estimation
setting when you want very high rates of
success
and unique to non-non-gaussian
estimation problems so thanks very much
for your attention and
let's do questions
so just to make sure i understand there
was this more naive notion of an r
center namely one which just has small
spectral norm
uh difference so that it would it would
simultaneously
uh sorry from 60 of them so that you
wouldn't be changing
which 60 depends on uh
on the unit vector right and you're and
you're saying that the ground truth
simply does not satisfy that for our
star i would have to throw in uh
it does satisfy that for our star the
problem is that lots of other matrices
do
too and if that's your only criterion
for picking a matrix
but isn't this a strong isn't this a
stronger property
sorry sorry sorry i see what you're
saying uh that's right no it does not
satisfy it for our star
that might be good my mistake yeah okay
uh in fact in most cases these z's these
z matrices
they'll actually be rank deficient right
like they
i might they might even uh you know they
might even be
ranked you know constant rank or
something in which case their spectral
norm to the
distance to the covariance is very high
like a constant
um alex wein asks is that easy to
explain what your planted distribution
is
yeah it's not it's not hard um i can i
can actually
do that really quick probably uh the
okay now airplay decides to freeze um
what you do alex is you put in
um you you like pick the buckets ahead
of time i'm just
resetting my screen share here um like
you
uh you decide that you know you look
with what buckets the algorithm is going
to choose
okay so you assume that you can know
those and then what you do is um
so you have your samples like x1 xn that
i want to create here are the buckets
and in half the buckets what i will do
is i will make them be samples from
normal
zero identity plus uh
vv transpose for some v and in the other
half the buckets i'll make them be iid
samples from normal zero identity
minus vb transpose for some v okay
so that if you look at the overall
covariance of everything it'll still
look like identity
but there'll be this planted direction v
okay i have to put some you know put the
right scaling in and everything but
there'll be some there'll be some
direction v
where identity is actually far from any
of the bucketed
bucketed covariances but so
are you it seems like this is a
distribution on
the buckets these are not buckets that
could actually arise from the random
bucketing
um yeah so you
need you know the algorithm doesn't have
to do random
bucketing the algorithm can just put the
first
block of samples into the first bucket
and the next block of samples into the
next bucket and the next block into the
next bucket and so on
but you're right that random bucketing
would seem to
defeat this uh this counter example
as i said you know this is like pretty
mild evidence of a road block
it's it's what we've got but i'm not
saying it's terribly convincing
uh so andres i i'm no longer the host
but andres
has a couple of questions in the q a
andres you can unmute yourself if you
want
tim has a follow-up question about the
quarter
um so again so the the ground truth
inference version of this
is to think of right that there is a
ground truth and then you have
n noisy teachers that have some unknown
error covariance matrix
right yeah i guess in the sense that
each
each each sample is some kind of teacher
about
about the thing you want to estimate
exactly for each
so for example in for x1 right something
comes down it's so it's an online r
uh kind of uh algorithm
x1 comes down the line and the end noisy
teachers are going to perturb it with
some unknown error covariance matrix
right so that's it's a different problem
from what you're doing
right but i'm i'm just pointing out that
in that one
right you can actually recover it using
these error moments algebraic equations
and you can only do it if for uh what i
would call precision error
because you can't compute the bias right
you you have to demean the signal if you
will
of all the uh your noisy estimators
but that problem is is is solvable when
you know they're sparse in their
correlations of the errors that they
make
certainly when they're independent of
the error on the ground truth
but uh sparsely correlated they can be
recovered
but as they become more correlated then
it's going to become unsolvable again
so again so i mean right it sounds like
there's that in some other problem
related there are
information computation gaps and exactly
exactly exactly so the the question here
that i want to highlight though is
whether whether there are gaps that
especially emerge when you want to do
very
very high probability um kind of
estimation
uh i'm happy to to discuss this further
offline if you want i'm around on the
discord and and you can find
my email online and things like that i
work i'm short of time so maybe we can
go to tim quickly or or chris are we out
of time
tim are you unmuted now um yeah i'm
unmuted you'll see the last question
okay i was just curious if there's some
very
like brief explanation or thing you can
point to
here that explains where this exponent
one quarter
uh comes from specifically rather than
anything else
uh
so it seems yeah okay i mean
i think for you what i can what if for
you what i can say
is that it's the same this is not going
to be so ineligible to a lot of folks
but
right now this is exactly it's the same
one quarter as what
it's the same one quarter as uh as like
the n3 quarters
in tensor pca or the
number of clauses to the three halves in
uh random
3x because our certification algorithm
goes via the same
approach we we turn the thing into you
know basically a three csp
and then we do refutation on the threes
it's not really a three csv but it's the
same kind of random matrix structure
and then you do refutation on that cool
all right
thanks very cool i guess i guess you
lean towards hardness of this problem
below the one quarter right
well for certification i think it's hard
uh i i mean i
admit there are some drawbacks to this
hard instance but but i think for
certification
it's hard for for estimation improving
the one quarter i really have no idea
i i'm total i'm neutral on it i don't
know
all right let's thank sam and we'll um
so
we will come back in 6.5 minutes for
amin's talk
thank you